welcome back so we're talking about this
new document this roadmap 2030 that
describes how control theory is going to
be Central for addressing societal scale
challenges in the next decade and Beyond
and this uh chapter that I'm going to
talk about right now chapter five is all
about how to actually translate this
into kind of industrial scale
applications through technology
validation and translation so this is
something I think is super duper
important something
um kind of I know a lot of the controls
Community has been passionate about for
a long time so most of the great control
theorists I know actually apply their
theory in practice on actual industrial
problems and this is talking about how
we can kind of accelerate and broaden
those efforts so if we really want to
solve some of these societal scale
challenges like climate change you know
making our power grid more resilient
things like that we have to have
technology that is you know bomb proof
Ironclad and is definitely validated and
going to work in these industrial
applications
so this is a great quote
um that is quoted in this road map by
Stephen Lowe the gap between theory and
practice is a lot bigger in practice
than in theory and I think that's really
a clever way of saying that there is a
long way to go between what we do in
kind of mathematical control theory and
the scale of you know deployed solutions
that we need at scale for industrial
control and this is a really cool table
from again this roadmap that illustrates
just kind of how large some of these uh
some of these different kind of markets
and Industrial sectors are so you know
Automotive control for example this is a
63 billion dollar volume of sales per
year
percent growth over here so this is a
kind of useful information if you're
thinking you know what are the sectors
that are really big and growing how fast
are they growing you know uh kind of
what do they look like so I think this
is really helpful for me also when I
think about developing new technology
you know to understand what the trends
are and where things are going
um this is pretty useful so there are
also recommendations for um essentially
how you actually
get the research Community kind of the
academic controls Community to make
technology that is more useful and more
broadly applicable in industry and can
be validated I'm not going to read this
off for you but this is pretty useful
these are 10 messages for the control
research Community this is from another
document that was reprinted with
permission
um
but you know for example number three I
think a super important real world
success requires domain understanding
this is true in all fields of academic
research not just in control theory this
is also true in machine learning and
data science if you have skills like
control theory like machine learning and
you want to go into someone else's
domain whether that's biological systems
or the power grid if you don't either
work with someone who has a domain
knowledge respect that domain knowledge
or yourself build that domain knowledge
in that field you're really going to be
hamstringing yourself and limiting your
future success so I think that's really
really important real world success
requires domain understanding and
respecting that deep domain knowledge
problems are hard or else they would
have been solved and you're not just
going to come in and kind of solve
everyone's problems with control theory
if you don't understand what their real
challenges are okay and there's a lot of
good recommendations here that's just
one that jumped out to me okay so this
chapter is really thinking about how is
this transition from these kind of
emerging methodologies and new control
techniques how do we get these new
um you know methodologies of control
into industrial Solutions in a way that
they really are robust they really do
solve problems okay a lot of good
recommendations here
similarly some cool kind of just uh ways
of understanding the process of
validation so one of the really key
takeaways in this entire chapter I said
it at the beginning and we're going to
see it much more in the the second half
of this video is
validation and benchmarks are essential
for demonstrating that technology is
ready to transition into kind of actual
Prime Time industrial scale
uses okay so before my little control
theory widget is on every self-driving
car you know across the world it had
better been validated and benchmarked
and test rigorously by the community in
an open and transparent way so that's
one of the things that this chapter
really Advocates is the need for
Benchmark validation systems that allow
us to move the field forward and so this
is just kind of one cool graphic from
this chapter on kind of the process of
validation from fundamentals to
applications to prototype in this kind
of theory to application progression
and maybe I'll just talk a little bit
about some of those um benchmarks
because I think that'll be pretty useful
um so so what are some of the desired
features of a validation infrastructure
that allows us to take our academic
theoretical work and move it into the
kind of industrial scale problems and
maybe I'll make a point here this is
important
this is a huge Community Control
theorists there are you know tons and
tons of people practicing control theory
all the way from the extremely
mathematical essentially you know
mathematicians whose problem space
happens to be dynamical systems and
controls optimization all the way to
extremely applied researchers who are
actually implementing you know control
Solutions on Hardware in industrial
settings okay there's this huge
progression and one person doesn't have
to be able to do all of it that's
actually one of the the most important
things about Benchmark systems and
validation infrastructure is it allows
people at different progressions at
different technical Readiness levels to
talk to each other and so if I'm on the
very applied side I can grab
methodologies on the very peer side and
if I'm on the very pure side I can kind
of interface and have my technology move
towards the more industrial side without
me being one of those industrial experts
and so these are some of the
um kind of key takeaways summarized in
this chapter things you need your
validation Benchmark infrastructure to
have you need to have Fidelity you need
your testbed to be as close to the real
world environment as possible while
still maintaining the fact that it's a
test bed it's tractable it's low cost
it's fast to prototype on things like
that and so sometimes that might mean
that there is a hierarchy of fidelities
you might have you know a low Fidelity
model that you really rapidly prototype
on and then you move up infidelity you
kind of have your your different control
strategies move up in Fidelity until
they reach test beds that really are as
accurate as possible this is what we do
in aviation with flight simulators
there's a whole range of graded uh
fidelities of flight simulators and you
use different ones for different
validation uh kind of for different
validation Necessities okay
repeatability this again is not just
specific to control theory this is for
you know all of science we need
reproducibility and repeatable
experiments and when you have a
validation infrastructure in particular
those have to be repeatable so that if I
run a control experiment in
um you know Tokyo and I run one in Los
Angeles those get the same results if
it's the same test bed and the same
control architecture so reproducibility
and repeatability is essential
measurement accuracy of course we need
to actually be able to tell
the difference between different control
algorithms on different Benchmark
problems so we need to actually be
measuring enough information about the
system that we can make good conclusions
without changing the course of those
experiments so there's a little bit of
that kind of quantum Observer uh flavor
to this you have to be able to measure
your system without changing the outcome
and actually in Quantum control that is
actually an interesting Challenge and
then of course safe execution is a
important thing here some of these are
things like safe self-driving cars or
robotics where even the test bed itself
has some kind of you know risks
associated with running these so you
need them to be safe I for example have
this double pendulum experiment in my
lab and if it is used incorrectly it
could actually be dangerous so that's
um you know important for us to very
safely use this as a test bed system
actually this is my double pendulum this
is the one that has to be used with care
and caution and this is just one example
of a benchmark system many many people
across the world have used single
pendulum double pendulum triple pendulum
as you know toy Benchmark systems to
test new learning and control algorithms
because it's you know a simple but
chaotic non-linear dynamical system we
know the equations and we can kind of
rapidly prototype and play around with
this I'm just actually pointing out here
that you know if I only used as a
benchmark system the equation for a
double pendulum and I only did all of my
benchmarking in simulation I would
actually miss a lot of the real world
complexity because there are there's
physics missing from our idealized
lagrangian Dynamics things like wind
resistance and bearing chatter and so
you actually need the Fidelity of a real
experiment
um you know to capture those
discrepancies between the real world and
that idealized setting so remember that
Fidelity sometimes you need an actual
hardware test bed to match the Fidelity
in the kind of challenges you'll see in
the real world this is just one example
for my lab it's kind of a toy system
um another so one of the things I really
like about this chapter and I I learned
a lot when I was reading this because
I'm very hungry for Benchmark systems my
lab Works in um you know learning and
machine learning for control so we're
constantly trying to find new Benchmark
systems where we can go and apply our
methods in those Benchmark systems and
reading this chapter I saw dozens of you
know data sets and Benchmark systems and
standards and protocols that I actually
hadn't heard of or been aware of so
that's hopefully very useful for you too
you should go read this document and go
find those benchmarks and find the one
that's useful for you one of the ones
that is pretty common that most of us
know about is this open AI gym so before
chat GPT the fame of large language
models uh open AI was also developing
these reinforcement learning Benchmark
environments this open AI gym that has
things like Atari games or robotic
simulations or you know single and
double pendula swing up prop so kind of
a whole range from Toy robotic systems
all the way to video game systems where
you can test your reinforcement learning
control algorithms so this has been
really game changing for the
reinforcement learning community and we
in the broader controls Community need
to embrace this kind of very open very
transparent Benchmark for our work in
the future
again in my lab we work a lot in fluid
flow control because fluids are
everywhere and the ability to control
these dramatically will change our
ability to for example you know make
better efficient cars and trains and
trucks and planes which might have a you
know mitigating effect on on things like
climate change so flow control is
important uh researchers in my group in
particular Jared Callahan ludger payler
and Sam honored have essentially
developed this kind of hydrogen
Benchmark validation environment in the
open AI
kind of API the uh AI gym API so you can
develop controllers and try them on this
much harder class of non-linear fluid
flows again just one example but we as a
community when we have a problem we
think is important that we want everyone
to work on we need to be making these
validation Benchmark systems for people
to come together and in a very
transparent and open way develop and
test technology on the problems we care
about
um this is a really cool video
um I got from from uh one of the
organizers Professor Johansen one of the
organizers of this um editors of this
this roadmap that essentially talks
about you know if we want uh autonomous
vehicles and we want coordination and we
want um you know all of these different
agents to be working together with
autonomy self-driving cars things like
that you need to have a again flexible
validation test bed Benchmark system so
this is an example of this
um that I believe is uh coordinated at
least in part by kth in Stockholm that
essentially has this ecosystem test bed
for autonomy with different like little
self-driving cars you they're simulated
and real physical assets so you can have
you know different levels of fidelity
and complexity and expense so you can
really test lots of control and you know
distributed control Network control
autonomy all kinds of different
algorithms items you can test it in this
kind of vehicle traffic control tower so
similar to an air traffic control tower
this is kind of you know that level of
awareness and um and Fidelity but for
you know autonomous autonomous vehicles
and so the ones I showed you before were
really toy Benchmark systems very
academic this is the kind of you know
moving more towards real Industrial
Research the kind of validation and
Benchmark system that we're going to
need to get those Technologies actually
into you know fleets of autonomous
autonomous vehicles anyway I think this
video is really cool
um you know I'll hopefully put a link in
the video so you can watch the whole
thing and yourself but hopefully what
you've seen is really this very high
level
need if we want our technology to
actually solve these societal scale
problems then we're going to need these
validation Benchmark infrastructures at
various fidelities at various costs at
various kind of levels of realism so
that we can transition that technology
into actual you know industrial uh
deployment okay thank you